the fact that the media is giving this
guy air time
when right now there are hundreds of
thousands of people
including children in concentration
camps i have
absolutely just utter contempt for the
fact that this is getting an airplay
now in the book you have him the book is
terrible but the book is terribly funny
i'm john tierney welcome to the museum
of sex i am here
for a discussion of a very unusual book
it's an unauthorized autobiography
it's called dear reader it's the
unauthorized autobiography of kim
jong-il
and and with me is dear writer
uh michael malus now michael he he
brings an interesting background to this
he was he was born in ukraine
um under communist rule came at a very
early age to brooklyn
and uh he has been a ghostwriter
for uh for for um autobiographies of
brett michaels the the rock star the
ultimate fighting champ matt hughes the
comedian
d l hugh hugely uh he co-wrote
concierge confidential so it must have
been different i imagine
working with kim jong-il
the dear leader and i wonder if you
could just start by telling us how you
got the idea for this book and how you
worked with a great man
well as kim jong-il says it takes a
great man to understand a great man
that's a quote from the book no i was
working on another project
and it wasn't going so hot and my friend
took me out of the house and in arizona
and he said hey you should write kim
jong-il's autobiography
and i thought this is just a brilliant
idea because he's probably the most
famous person
out there that would never write his own
autobiography at least not for american
audiences and everyone has an awareness
of him but few
people have a knowledge and information
about him so i
usually when i write an autobiography
you work with the person you interview
them they write you know you work
together
obviously kim jong-il was not available
to me because i'm not
because i'm not korean and he's deceased
so
uh these are two big hurdles i had to
overcome but
of course uh used being magic it was
easy to do
so i actually went to north korea and i
got stacks and stacks of the propaganda
and i read the entire western canon as
well about north korea so i read 60 six
zero books and i used that to adapt it
to a first person narrative of his life
and it mapped out perfectly to a history
of north korea because he was born in
world war
ii as north korea was becoming a country
he died in 2011.
so he's like their force gump whenever
anything of interest happens in north
korea kim jong-il's there
uh they they claim that even as a child
of age three he was sitting at his
father kimmel song's knee and advising
him against the wicked japs
so he's really at every point in time so
when you read this book and you learn
his life story
you're actually learning a life history
of north korea and how it got to be the
way it is
now how much of the pros in the book is
of the sentences are actually
things he said about you know for
instance he compared one of his
theories of literature i believe it was
equivalent to columbus discovery in
america yes
so another one of his was it was it was
compared to
the discovery of fire i believe right
right so it's very
uh there's all these superlatives that
they use in the propaganda which of
course every single one of them i cut
and pasted because they were just
amazing
they compared his uh college thesis
which was the role of the county in
building socialism hardly groundbreaking
work even by their standards
so that was i think comparable to
columbus discovering america
uh and and the copernican revolution is
compared to i think his
theory of art so every time they use
some profound sense of phrase
of praise i absolutely use their own
language in fact one of the books one of
the biographies of him called the
people's leader
they talk about as he grew up he learned
many qualities from the communist
guerrillas including
manliness magnanimity intelligence hard
working
and modesty
but they ended on modesty and i'm like
are they
taunting us so that that's in there i
have that as a as a little sidebar of
the qualities he learned at his father's
knee
now did he um did you have much stuff in
his words his speeches or
what did you have to work with yeah one
of the things people ask me often is how
do you know what he really thought
and the idea that anyone in north korea
could have any doubt what kim jong-il
thought about anything
is absolutely as absurd as some of the
stories because he wrote about
gymnastics magic tricks dance
architecture
the cinema literature war politics
history
uh cooking um apparently koreans lack an
enzyme and that's why they have to eat
kimchi um
so it is some of his scientific work i
guess
well he also discovered that a
paleolithic man originated on the korean
peninsula
and in fact when he told the north
korean archaeologist where to look
that's exactly where they found the
remains
what a genius
um and korean was one of the first
languages spoken by men and korea was
the first government on earth
of course now um how much of this stuff
did i mean did you have any sense for
how much of this
he really believed or um we do have
people in north korea believed also
because you were there
we do have a great sense of what he
really believed for several reasons
uh as we saw recently with kim jong-un
killing his
uncle a lot of high-level people have
defected over the years
including the man who invented the term
juche which is the leading philosophy of
north korea
so many members of his inner circle have
fled uh
you know because for fear for their
lives and even being wealthy
you know in north korea when you have a
gun to your head you know it's like the
sort of damocles kind of situation
so we really have a good understanding
of how he thought we also
uh there were several instances where
people had hidden tape recorders
and they spoke to him and it's just
fascinating to hear his concerns
you know when he when he thinks the
cameras are off well he's only spoken
one sentence in public ever which is
glory to the korean people's
revolutionary army
that's the only thing he's ever said in
public just one sentence so now everyone
here is a
world authority on his public speeches
but
what's terrifying and his son of course
defected but what's terrifying
is you know during the famine in the 90s
which you know devastated the economy in
the country
he's concerned that the korean breed of
dog is being driven to extinction
so it's it's his priorities were very
very clear korea but not the korean
people
themselves uh and you know he put that
plan into
practice with bloody consequences um
now in the book you have him talking
about that that he was upset when he saw
the famine that there was just craft
people weren't eating but he then went
home and went to
right to work on it right oh yeah well i
mean they claim that he wears those
sunglasses because he's bloodshot from
staying up all night
uh trying to fix the country um and
the famine there's a big misconception
people in america have about kim jong-il
this is the one thing i want everyone to
understand uh he is despised
there uh his father came it's like this
let's suppose you met someone from
another country and they said they love
american music
and they said they they love nancy
sinatra she's there she's their favorite
artist she's the best they love her
songs love her style
and you say great what do you think of
frank sinatra and they say who
and and that is how kim jong-il is
compared to his father kim il-sung
everything in the country is a function
of his father
but most americans only know the sun and
in fact when kim jong-il took over in 94
with his father kim il-sung's death
that's when the famine hit so he either
got the blame
or he for causing it or at least not
preventing it so
it's very easy to convince an isolated
population that they're wealthy and the
world envies them
it's almost impossible to convince
someone they have more food in their
plate than they did last year
or that their children you know aren't
starving so there's propaganda can only
go so far so he is really reviled
and he was aware of this in fact you
know he he cut his teeth on the korean
cinema which is true
and when the people were cheering for
him he was caught saying this isn't
coming from the bottom of their hearts
this is all fake so he knew
that he was reviled in north korea they
called him the gruel lord you know
because people
by the end they were hopeful to have
gruel they were eating you know
saccharine just to have something in
their stomachs
now growing up um it's very fun i mean i
mean the book is terrible to read about
the
terrible and i mean it's hilarious what
is this npr
yeah no and
it's terrible as far as this say that
but
it's it's a hilarious read is what i'm
trying to get to here
because he just you know he'll be
talking about that he um
he came up with the idea um in grade
school i think was
of self-criticism oh yeah he realized
this and he said he did this
and he didn't realize how popular it
would be right
so one of you know people don't
understand what life is like under
totalitarian
dictatorship and one of the most telling
things of what it's like is everyone in
the country
every single person starting from grade
school once a week has to engage in a
self-criticism session
uh you're funneled into a neighborhood
group your school union something
everyone's in some group it's called
their organizational life
and once a week you have to get up in
front of all your peers and say
these are the mistakes i made these this
week and then all your peers get
up and denounce you in front of
everybody else and this happens
weekly for everyone in the entire
country
so we think totalitarianism is kind of
like
you know you're forbidden to do certain
things or you're not allowed to leave
your house there is no element of north
korean life
where the people's lives aren't
regimented and under the thumb of the
state
uh and and you can imagine you're
starting elementary school you know how
in front of your whole school like your
friends have to be like i saw you doing
this
everyone's watching everyone else and
kind of stuff will they confess you know
well yeah it's like i was late for work
or you know i wasn't
paying attention to this paperwork as
much as i should have
and the thing is you have to have
something to confess so a lot of times
you know when you get older people have
a friend and they say i'll say you did
this you say i did that because if you
if you're claiming to be perfect well no
one's perfect but the great leader and
the dear leader another martial
so that's going to bring even worse
consequences and the other thing is
north korean is a collectivist society
and punishment is collective so when bad
things happen to you they happen to your
whole family
so you really have a big gun to your
head that you better
you know follow suit or else you know
mom dad sister cousins will
suffer the consequences and they boast
about this
people you know constantly i mean
american politicians rick santorum
uh everyone's hero uh often says the
family is the basic unit of society well
what that means in practice is if you
commit a crime your family should go to
jail that's what unit means isn't it
does he not speak english
it's my second language i don't know
maybe he should make it his first
um did you get a sense from this
as far as it's the development of the
country and of him that i mean growing
up
he was the son of of the great leader
right i mean he calls him marshall in
general throughout i didn't see any dads
father yeah no he is in fact they boast
that his mom
always referred to him as general and
never as husband yeah
because it's communist so the the
person's role is more important than
blood ties
right so were people terrified of him
his whole life then i mean it's very
funny in school when they said you know
the professor said
when he takes issue with the professor
about something professor says there is
nothing with you that i can argue yeah
of course
so right so they claim he revolutionized
all the universities
uh while he was at university it's just
an amazing thing they were not terrified
of him growing up
because the idea that a son would
succeed his father in a communist state
is insane it completely flies against
all communist propaganda and philosophy
and in fact there was a huge backlash in
1980
when kim il-sung named kim jong-il as
his successor because this was just a
complete repudiation of marxism and
any kind of you know anti-hierarchical
society and it wasn't at all
the case that it was clear that he would
uh take over as i go into in the book
uh him and his uncle uh you know kind of
foreshadowing what happened recently him
and his uncle had a little war to see
who would take over
and that's the big part of this
personality cult around his father
kimmel sung
was a consequence of each of them trying
to show how loyal they were
to the dad who finally settled on the
sun and culminating of course in that
six-story high statue
in pyongyang of kim il-sung which was
originally plated in gold until i
believe it was mao who said you know
we're communist maybe a gold icon
in our capital city isn't what we're
about so now it's in bronze which is
much more you know tame
yeah and and very populist now um
i wonder if you're thinking of a
follow-up on this about his time
management techniques because
he said in college he said he read
every classical book of philosophy and
everything else he mastered them all
mastered every science every art right
um he also saw every movie that was out
chicken farming and he wrote it's a
great reading list it's got like
chicken farming and gemstones and
in addition to that one called he wrote
1 400 works
including these that were compared to
that 1400 works i included that because
a lot of times people in the states or
in the west get the propaganda wrong
he did write 1400 works in college
because they say
works including letters essays and and
books so if that works out to one letter
a day everyone here has written 1400 uh
works over college
so it's a lot of times the propaganda
like for example they never the uncle
wasn't eaten by dogs
uh people are so used to thinking of
north korea as
bonkers and they are bonkers in a sense
but they're not bonkers in the sense
that they're unpredictable
uh they're they very much have a clear
coherent philosophy
which most western uh people do not have
an understanding of including people in
the media which is unfortunate
so part of what i had put forward in
this book is once you read it you will
understand why they do what they do
and it kind of reads like a murder
mystery we know who the victims are the
north korean people
we know who the perpetrators are and now
you find out their motive and their
means and how they
you know took this proud country and
just drove it into the ground into the
least free state on earth but you want
to give a real quick summary of
of how they did that i mean as far as
the uh the philosophy that led to that
well i mean it's 400 pages i mean the
quick summary the quick start
this is television here
they i mean i'll give you one sentence
they practice what they preached
they practiced what they preached when
they said nothing beyond the state
that everyone lives as a function of
their society
and when that philosophy is coherently
and perfectly put into practice and the
leader is the embodiment of the people
and only the leader has true life
and your life is a function of defending
the leader once those ideas are put into
practice
this is what you see you see a nation
that has no electricity
you see a nation where children are four
inches shorter than south korea
because of malnutrition uh you see a
complete
you know stalinist orwellian nightmare
with concentration camps because if
there's no such thing as human rights
uh then the idea that you can be sent to
in your family can be sent to a camp
makes perfect sense
now um people talk about the importance
of culture in developing a
a democracy or or a free society and
korea
is such an interesting because it's one
country that gets divided
very similar culture until suddenly th
this change happens do you have any
thoughts about
i mean i mean what um how little does it
take for something to go wrong for
culture to suddenly just
degenerate well i i think a lot of us in
the west think that our allies are good
guys and our enemies are bad guys and
usually our enemies are bad guys but
sometimes our allies are bad guys too
and
south korea was only democracy until
fairly recently and i mean
late 80s early 90s and in fact in early
in the early 80s they had their own
sandman square
massacre where the u.s was involved and
the us doesn't deny that they happened
there was this big uprising they came in
with tanks and they started killing
students and
uh you know this is something that's
kind of been swept into the rug so a lot
of the north korean propaganda about the
south was true you know after world war
ii
the u.s installed this kind of signatory
straw man and he was overthrown but
there was one
uh kind of dictator after another the
combination of which when i read this in
north korean prop again i'm like okay
this isn't true but it's
it's on wikipedia uh the head of the
south korean cia assassinated the
president and declared himself president
and he became the president
uh and it's just like wait what no that
really happened the first lady was
assassinated you know so there's all
sorts of
you know horrific things in the south
that you know we've kind of forgotten
but they share a lot of commonalities
they're extremely xenophobic
uh you know there's a lot of you know
korean pride and and uh you know
contempt for any kind of uh
you know strong racialism uh and things
like that and so
they're not as removed as as we'd like
them to be culturally
politically of course it's night and day
and that's a you know good metaphor
because at night
you know soul is lit up brightly and you
look at the nasa map
at night north korea is just a black
void
um but north korea does have a better
opera thanks to kim jong-il
well he revolutionized the opera opera
used to be about uh you know nobility
and prostitutes
uh but now it's for the people uh he
invented something called peng chang
which is off stage singing which
that was also copernicus i think they
compared to they kept comparing him to
copernicus so it
i kind of had to pick and choose the
metaphor discovery fire copernicus and
columbus were the big ones yeah
but how did the opera work so basically
you know in greek opera you have the
chorus
the choir on stage singing right uh to
narrate the thoughts of the
of the protagonist north korean opera is
completely different
because the choir is off stage so it's
nothing like the greek one cause they're
off stage
it's an operatic revolution and he
actually did this you know they had this
north korean opera they're very very
proud of it you know all the operas are
about the leader or
joining revolution or joining the party
but this was really their you know
innovative form of art
i've never seen one because i i've read
60 books i i've had enough of their
stuff it's just like please
i can read about it i don't need to
watch the flower girl you know
what was your sense when you were there
i was intrigued when you talked about
the being in a place like that which
sounds so awful that in in some ways it
reminded me when i
i was in poland when i was a communist
and the thing that did surprise me that
poland was fairly light communism by
things but it was it seemed more normal
i i lost my passport at one point
it was at the hotel and i thought oh my
god i'm behind the iron curtain without
a passport
and nobody really cared the police
didn't care and you and you found some
of that too is that right when you were
there
it's a mix of normalcy and and you know
being in another planet back in time is
how i called it
one of the things that really really
struck me uh and this is kind of a
telling anecdote when i
i you know i was born as you said in the
soviet union when i was a kid my mom
used to drag me to century 21 which is
this discount clothing store every
literally every weekend and i would
spend hours there and i'd go mad you
know and
i resented her enormously until i went
to north korea because
my guide you know is a young woman and
she's probably the equivalent of a
millionaire at north korean standards
she will never be able to buy a nice
dress she will never be able to buy
makeup she will never be able to buy
perfume
or hand lotion or lipstick because
there's none in the whole country if we
don't make it we don't want it
so it kind of helped me understand that
my mom you know growing up
she just wanted to look pretty and this
was not available to her
so of course it's going to give her you
know kind of a bit of a complex so
what i want people to understand is the
people in north korea are desperately
seeking
a normal human like you know iran in the
50s spoke before the house and american
activities committee and she just
commented she goes
it's hard for a people in a free society
understand what it's like to live under
a totalitarian dictatorship she's like
and in a way it's a good that you don't
you don't understand
imagine what it's like to live in a
nation where human life means nothing
less than nothing and you know it
and yes you visit your mother-in-law and
you have a picnic or whatever you try to
have some sense of normalcy
but there's absolutely no humanity
whatsoever and at night you're waiting
for that
you know door door bell to ring or knock
on the door rather
and knowing that anyone can do anything
to you at any time and there's no
repercussions for them
so it's it's they learn to do the dance
but they will never be free and they
know it and they increasingly know it
and that's really what's scary
um last question for me do you have any
predictions for what's going to happen
after reading
um is there any hope for north korea in
the near future do you think
in the near future no there's no hope
there's
there's two
there's two points i'll make one is if
we look at the the slaves post-civil war
uh look how horrible it was for them for
decades so even if tomorrow the regime
vanished
these people have never seen a computer
uh these people you know
they have no understanding of history
it's very very troubling that's number
one
number two is there was a quote i think
it was a steinbeck hemingway and they
said how did you go bankrupt and he
replied uh
two ways gradually and then suddenly so
when it happens it's going to be like
domino's look at romania and in fact
north korea is very aware of what
happened in romania where chancheska was
assassinated on tv
and they were making sure that's not
going to happen to them because in these
nations when
the regime goes down the leaders are
personally murdered you know look at
libya
look at iraq so they have a very vested
interest even if they no longer believe
in the gucci idea
in maintaining power and making sure
nothing ever changes
um open up for some questions now
received a psychiatric evaluation
actually what's really
tragic is he uh he
his first wife who's the mother of his
eldest son she went mad they sent her
abroad
to the exiled her to moscow for
treatment and also there was there's
other you know he drove
some people to madness by having them
under surveillance 24 7 not allowed to
leave their house
so he's even worse than people realize
but no he's never had psychiatric
coalition
i'm with the honorable and one more
thing they're against freudianism that's
part of the list of things they hate
well i mean it's they're very chaste and
aesthetic so any kind of sexuality is
very forbidden there they would not be
happy with you here at the museum of sex
they don't care about me because i'm not
korean so i'm a lost cause
as someone with the iran institute i'm
particularly interested in your
quotation
or your familiarity with ayn rand but
i own her copy of the phone head yeah i
do
but i got a few particularly curious
about how a kid from brooklyn and
by kid i mean our young fellow
got into this into the first place i
presume from
the way you talk so intelligently on the
subject that you
speak the language and you mean english
that's your said your second language
your first language my first language is
russian yeah yeah well do you
uh i understand that you speak korean
and
did you translate all of this how did
how did you go
that's a very good question how do i get
all these really want to know the
essence of sure aside from just a friend
taking you out
sure how did all of this evolve
i ran first so uh okay so well i iran
obviously was a huge influence on me
growing up and us having a shared
background you know mises and i were
born the same town in ukraine levov
which is also the uh hometown of massock
of masochism fame
um i don't know i know what that says
it's true say it
so um but we the living
this was this was my we the living um
because
we the living is from the perspective of
the the maybe keira the protagonist
wasn't an average girl but certainly
a typical or regular person living under
stalinism but
here i have it from the other
perspective i have it from the respect
of the guy at the top
and what he's implementing and his
ideology and why he's doing and
and there's something as an author uh
kind of fun having someone reveling
in uh censorship and public executions
and all these other things because again
they're not apologetic they own it
and they are proud of it and then they
boast about it so
this idea that you know this u.n human
rights report that came out like oh my
god this is
this has been known for decades and even
khrushchev was condemning them you know
for their wackiness
so rand was a you know we the living was
very much in mind
uh in fact when rand had this great
essay called the monument builders and
about how these totalitarian
dictatorships always build up these
great monuments
so when i was there and being taken
around to all these monuments that's all
i could think of
um but the books are translated into
several languages
for a couple of reasons one is the
conceit is that everyone in the world is
obsessed with the gucci idea and is
interested in learning about it
but also because every one of these uh
you know self-absorbed little
little dictatorships you know feels that
they're important and it's like if
people want to know about us we have to
give them that
availability we're not going to be the
bottleneck that keeps them from learning
about the jewish idea
which is the guiding light of the 21st
century as you know
i want to explain what that is the
briefly the juji
the juchi idea is a word that means
smurf
because you have juche gymnastics and gg
architecture and juche music and juche
opera
and what it amounts to in practice is
that which kim jong-il and kim il-sung
like
what they claim it means is that it's
first of all they only this year started
calling it the juche philosophy instead
of the juchi idea i don't know where
they made the switch it was always the
juicy idea
but the principle is that man is the
master of everything and decides
everything
redundant but that's their how they how
they phrase it so basically that
a man is at the highest of values and
everything in the world exists only to
serve man
and and you only live as part of a
collective
they have a very coherent and and clever
way of explaining it which is
a little bit like mirror image of rand
it's like lewis carroll meets you know
uh
objectivism which i go into in the book
which is really
kind of fun and fascinating because the
deduction just goes in complete opposite
directions
but how does that relate to the idea
that everything has to be korean
and you know he talks about the argument
when i when a professor
an economics teacher dared or gave a
lecture and dared to point out that
it's better to buy um
from someone who's good at selling
apples rather than trying to do
everything yourself basically
comparative advantage
and he stands up and denounces him and
that this can't be right well one of the
big denunciation is like the students
were learning russian and they're
walking around
pyongyang saying the capital of moscow
of russia's moscow and they're saying
this in russian he goes no
you should say the capital of korea's
pyongyang the example should be korean
so
everything is is so they're ultra ultra
ultra ultra nationalist right so they're
much closer to fascism than they are to
communism
in most senses um so i asked a refugee i
go if if this is a philosophy by koreans
for koreans
why according to you would anyone else
in the world care
and they never gave that answer but
you're not going to be questioning it
when you're told this when your whole
family is at gunpoint
so that's really a big gaping hole uh
in a kind of a big net of gaping holes
of their world view
um and there's no mona lisa oh he hates
the mona lisa i asked my mom i said why
does kim jong-il hate the mon lisa and
she paused
no doubt remembering her upbringing she
goes because it's ambiguous
and that's right art has to have a clear
message for all the people
and therefore it's good art that's the
criterion for good art
how's his golf game and how's that
reconciled with the amount of golf
courses in north korea
i believe there's only one golf course
in north korea uh
the the funny thing about kim jong-il is
like a lot of people focus on
supernaturalism it's more the superhuman
aspect
that he's really good at everything and
that also serves a purpose you see all
these pictures and newspapers of him
visiting factories
that is supposed to tell the people
things are bad but he's on the case
you know so he's good at everything and
and it'll be okay
you know daddy's here
i wanted to ask you i don't know how
much time you really spent in north
korea five days
okay it's not so much how do you think
people
actually uh change under such a regime
and how do they maintain their
humanity what happens to them uh
i mean we there's lots of parallels if
you look at like you know the
the jewish holocaust you look at slavery
you know how people try to maintain some
kind of semblance of humanity
it's through things they're they they
have great senses of humor
which is something that never even
entered my head uh they gossip with
their friends
you know you have family bonds that are
close uh
and it's again if you have these
criticism sessions you're encouraged to
be a gossip right because you're
supposed to be like
did you see what she did so that is a
big kind of
semblance but again it's it's it's it
it's the hardest place to maintain your
humanity on earth especially if you know
during the famine i can't even i i mean
i can't even wrap my head around it
thank god
um any uh north korean jokes you want to
share sure
um i asked my guide i said tell me a
north korean joke
and she goes okay guy ghost
guy goes mommy goes hey i don't want to
go to school today and i give you two
good reasons
one all the kids hate me and two all the
teachers hate me and the mom goes
son you have to go to school today i'll
give you two good reasons
one you're the principal and two you're
35 years old
it's funny and the fact that she had one
off the cuff
you know it it it just really oh and any
joke you tell them just about the
japanese
they love that yes
bastards well kim jong-il explicitly
said that whenever
you refer to a foreigner from a country
they hate which is japan or america
you don't say american you say yank
devil or [ __ ] bastard uh
and in fact they don't teach them that
in world war ii uh the u.s and japan
were antagonists because that's kind of
hard to explain um
so it's you know we've us in japan have
always been conspiring to kind of seize
korea
um i have two questions one
my mother went to north korea with the
asia society
and she said one of the most bizarre
things they did was go to this
incredible
amusement park which she said was one of
the most amazing
amusement parks she'd ever been to in
her life and they seemed
to let them speak to the
teenagers and twenty-somethings that
were there
um i mean i had assumed to her that they
were plants but she
claims that they managed to have some
side conversations and i wondered
what the hell that was about given this
i mean is that
all for a western show there's no way
that those weren't plants because you're
not allowed to talk to foreigners unless
you're really high up there's a
hierarchy there you have a
it's like a kind of like a credit rating
they have a caste system so
for someone to be trusted to talk to
foreigners you really have to be very
very trusted so just any kids is just
absolutely impossible
so what's that amusement park for well
the amusement parks are for the people
but the people who were
they knew they were coming that the
westerners were coming so of course they
were there to have people talk to them
i'm sure their conversations were
sincere
but i'm sure these people were
pre-screened and told you know what to
talk about what not to talk about
and secondly can you within all of this
insanity can you explain
our basketball friend
dennis rodman should have a bullet put
in him
anyone who goes on tv and when asked
about what about concentration camp
says we have prisons what's the
difference
which in is in the guise of a rhetorical
question but actually is a question that
would have an eight-hour answer
anyone who goes on tv and i'm not a fan
of this president and who tells the
president kim jong-un is waiting for
your call
and challenges the president on behalf
of a foreign nation anyone who humanizes
a regime
where the leader kills his own family
and the family of his family
i don't care how drunk crazy or stupid
you are
you are a monster uh this kind of little
lillian hellman you know nonsense so the
fact that the media
is giving this guy air time when
right now there are hundreds of
thousands of people including children
in concentration camps where men are
being sent to mines where their skin
will fall off because they will never
never see sunlight again and have
vitamin d deficiency i have
absolutely i just utter contempt for the
fact that this is getting any airplay
now in the book you have him talking the
book is terrible but the book is
terribly funny
it's it's a gift it's a gift
it is though right well it does have
great touches like like when he's
talking about the um
the airplane flight that was there and
he said that
there was a korean agent accused of it
he said and that was ridiculous of
course because
if i use someone i go abduct japanese
women why don't you tell us about it so
there's this great
this is a great great story and this the
the craziest stuff i left in and i
didn't i didn't change it because it's
so crazy that people don't believe it
then they go on wikipedia like oh
everything of this is true
in 1988 uh or seoul seoul was granted
the 1988 olympics
and kim jong-il said hey wouldn't it be
great if north korea and south korea
co-hosted
and south korea goes okay the olympics
aren't granted to a country they're
granted to a city which is seoul so that
doesn't make sense
and it's not for us to share with you
and he's like come on and they're like
that doesn't make any sense
you don't even have any facilities he's
like come on and they're like no
and he's like okay so he sent an agent
to put a bomb on one of their airliners
the bomb went and she got off
her into her heart and man they got off
they were apprehended
they start smoking cyanide-laden
cigarettes he
he died she did not she was captured
taken to south korea everyone died
she went on tv she announced what she
had done
mia culpa she was pardoned
by the south korean president because
she was brainwashed
by kim jong-il and kim il-sung let me
repeat that
a woman went on tv admitted to blowing
up a plane and killing everyone on board
and she received the pardon
not a commutation she's walking around
now south korea
happy as can be uh it would really be
like clinton
you know pardoning timothy mcveigh so
south korea is a pretty
wacky place uh and that's the you know
her whole story she had a book deal here
uh you know so i i don't know it's it's
it's pretty
nuts but then what did then how did he
respond when he was accused of sending
the agent
oh right so so the point is kim jong-il
is not perfect
because he has publicly apologized once
which is for the following
for for years japanese citizens were
vanishing
you know from beaches from shopping
malls and people thought this was north
korea abducting them but they were like
random you know there's nothing in
common
and of course a lot of people in the
left uh in
academia no doubt said you guys are
ready to believe everything about north
korea come on they're not that crazy
well uh during the famine uh
the japanese in 2001 the japanese prime
minister came to north korea
and kim jong-il said yeah about all
those abductions
my bad uh it was one of my people but
they've been punished it'll never happen
again
so will you give us more rice now please
and he's like wait what and he's like
yeah no this is this really happened
sorry i'm
so sorry can we have reparations for
world war ii and they're like no
and and the japanese had so much food
that they were
they didn't have storage space and they
literally threw it in the ocean rather
than send it to north korea
after these confessions and kim jong-il
was like i don't get it i apologize
it's like and that is all true
hey so why was he abducting them again
he was abducting them to train them to
be spies to teach them japanese teach
them japanese mores and in fact the
woman who bombed the plane when she was
caught by the south korean cia
and she was claiming insisting she was
japanese they're like okay
uh what street did you grow up on what
was your favorite tv show what was your
favorite candy and she's like kim
jong-il street
uh the kim jong-il show i mean
she's had no exposure to the rest of the
world how she could be able to guess any
of these things
uh you mentioned earlier um that people
were shocked or surprised
that uh the son was selected as a
successor
what might they have expected instead
well i mean if you look at every other
communist country they have
you know someone who's the head of you
know the army or the head of the korean
people's
the workers party of korea which is
their you know their their political
party
so you know the idea that the son who
wasn't a military figure either
would be taking over this militaristic
nation was just completely
just whacked
we got let's get the mic to andrews
um do you want to talk more about why
they didn't make that decision i mean
you mentioned about it having to do with
loyalty but it's still
interesting like what was it i don't
know or
do we have to read the book well no i
mean definitely read the book
because this is the one of the great
things that i learned while writing this
book
is that all the criticism that is
leveled at them they don't sweep it on
the rug
they look at it they put it out so when
i wrote this book you get the western
perspective and you get the northern
response
so they look at it they spell out the
western analysis and they go this is why
it's wrong
so he owns the fact that this was weird
that he was the successor
but he puts it forward as look at
khrushchev look at all these other
countries when you have look at you know
bush after reagan uh what's the guy's
name after thatcher uh
john major when you don't have a good
successor the revolution
goes to pot and you know that i'm just
like my dad so it makes sense that we're
going to continue through the
generations
and in fact in 94 when kim jong-il took
over
people think this is a joke when i add
in the book and it's not his campaign
slogan was
do not expect any change for me
that's what the billboards all said
more of the same more of the same he's
the
it worked 100 to vote
yeah but he says in your book now that
he does not have concentration camps
though right right they they
they don't call them they're what north
korea again was recently
attacked for concentration camps and
they their answer is and this is
i can't make this up we don't use the
term political prisoner camps in north
korea and therefore we don't have them
so there that takes care of that
did you did you get any sense of uh the
possibility of an underground or
subversion in any sense
or there is impossible there there's no
underground whatsoever but there is
subversion in this sense
uh when you don't have food you can't
pay your thugs
so you have the border guards between
the the river between north korea and
china
and that's gotten very very porous
because people go over
they get they sell ginseng in china and
or whatever they do
then they bring food back and those
guards who are there they get their cut
so and that's how a lot of information
is getting into
the dprk so that's the and
the subversion is they're not believing
they had to change the propaganda the
propaganda used to be you know we're the
happiest place on earth
but now the propaganda is we're the only
ones maintaining korean-ness
and we're building like a better future
we're poor but we're united
so that is a very important shift and
again it used to be that they fed
everybody
and now it's kind of like find your own
food so they they no longer boast about
like we're taking care of you
so these are big changes they've had to
kind of uh
deal with why did they
i mean what happened for a while they
were actually doing
better economically than south korea but
then what brought on the famine
sure they were you know south korea was
an agrarian backwater for many many
years
uh and north korea had huge because they
played
china versus russia and they were
basically a welfare state
uh and they got a lot of money and
they're doing well for themselves and
and
in the other sense is when you level an
entire country like we did to them
during the korean war the fatherland
liberation wars they call it
it's very easy to get economic growth
when you're starting with zero i mean
it's like 100 economic growth now i have
a rock you know
so so the statistics are skewed in that
sense
um but the famine hit because with the
collapse of the soviet union and the
welfare payments that stopped going to
them
uh and the fact that they were the only
communist nation to default in their
loans
uh everyone started to demand getting
payment in
you know hard currency which they did
not have so they
lost gasoline shipments and once you
lose gasoline you lose electricity and
once you lose
electricity you're done because they
have they're very mountainous regions
they have to have a lot of fertilizer
so they can't build food they can't have
cars they
converted many of their cars to wood
burning which is not a very effective
method to move a vehicle so
but i mean it's funny we laugh but i
mean this is the only thing
that that wood burning got some people
fed so i mean it's just really awful
yes it's easy for us to see the flaws
since we're outsiders
for north korea but has writing this
book giving you any insight into
things about the us that we might not be
aware of oh
oh boy
there is no much care okay on my camera
his critiques of u.s foreign policy are
really
spot-on and fun because
when he when we all laugh at kimmel's
song and the stories about him
and i have kim jong-il point out well in
america
they are of the belief that the greatest
minds in history all just happen to be
localized on the east coast in the 18th
century of america
and that the constitution is magic and
also his attack on this kind of american
heavy-handedness that we can just go in
in any other nation and topple their
regime and just leave it a complete ruin
so those were some valid points
but also this you know the the
propaganda of like you know
obviously kim jong-il and kim il-sung
are beatified basically
in north korea but we have our own
secular saints here and frank nelson
mandela
martin luther king lincoln you know if
anyone
i had a friend who pointed out that
lincoln you know didn't particularly
care for ending slavery
as long as he preserved the union
something he said constantly repeatedly
and
he was called a liar you know so it's
there's a lot of these a lot of what
they do is not unique to them it's part
of the human condition and it really
is kind of eye-opening and the whole
thing every politician
everywhere probably will say i'm
fighting for you and that's you know
that's what they're saying over there
too
um i have a question about the the
occasional
well the rare family reunification days
that they allow
what's what's in it for them why do they
allow this
i mean you were talking about porosity
before the border patrol and then
the plants and the the carnival
there there's this how do they can't say
you can't watch these videos without
crying
um so these families were separated as a
result of the korean war and these
people hadn't seen each other for
literally decades like 30 years 40 years
they had no word from each other
and they kind of had this daytime with
the south and they let families reunite
in pamela jam or places like that and
you see brothers who haven't seen each
other in 30 years
or like a dad who saw his daughter when
she was six and now she's got kids and
she's like 40.
and you watch them hugging and it's just
the most
wonderful thing you know on earth
possible
and this was there there's a couple
things a they are
desperately interested in reunification
according to their propaganda
uh and b it humanizes them uh and see
it you know south korea is a big sponsor
of them it's a way for them to kind of
get money for them like look we're
giving it's kind of this tit-for-tat
kind of thing of de-escalating tensions
and they can easily point to this is
look reunification is coming
uh it's the it's the wicked americans
who are keeping it uh separated so
i encourage anyone to go on youtube and
just look for the korean reunification
and
will just blow your mind it's just
wonderful um but i'm wondering if
if each pairing is not
monitored by a minder oh they are
monitored those are oh no no those
people were all carefully chosen
okay they had someone there with them
this was not they're not going on a trip
to hawaii
and they are not they don't i don't
think they had further contact either
it's like oh great you had your moment
come with us okay so it's just a quick
hug
i don't think it was quick i think
that's permanent i think they had a day
but
the conversation is permitted but
someone's standing right here
okay yeah but you know what honestly if
you don't see your family for 40 years
uh you don't need to say things that are
indiscreet you have lots to catch
up on that that are sure completely
politically acceptable to the north
and as long as you say everything's
great
why would north korea be
excited and push reunification unless
they believe that they're going to
remain in power
of the entire peninsula that's exactly
why uh kimbel sung's
ten point plan and he had a four-point
plan is was basically
his version of confederalism and you
have this half has their own system
this half has their own system and then
you've got the president
do you wonder who that's going to be um
so
you know i was the klaus fits who said
you know uh politics is just war by
other means so this was just their
attempt to kind of you know
and they really do have this obsession
with korea
the unified nation so they they want it
for you know genuine reasons and you
can't really blame them
and they look at you know and the one of
the things i have him talk about in the
book which they talk about is people
think reunification is never going to
happen he points out he goes look at
germany
uh look at what happened in ireland with
the peace accord he goes it's never too
late and as he says
if you're saying the word impossible
you're not speaking korean
to follow up on that though i mean uh
the german example is
surely appazite uh i mean the east
germany
collapsed and and became part of the
western capitalist state so they really
believe that that's a model i mean
clearly not well they believe that it's
it's
it's some it's a model in the sense that
uh
korea was united for far longer than
germany had was you know germany only
became a nation in the 1800s so it's not
at all implausible
yeah it's going to be hard but that we'd
be back together and they resent
enormously
uh the reason they point to germany is
that as a consequence of world war ii
only two nations were divided germany
and and
and korea and korea was an antagonist so
why are we the ones being separated in
germany who
really did bad things are all unified
and you know uh kind of leading europe
i guess i was curious about the
copernicus columbus reference
is that specifically geared towards
americans or do they expect north
koreans to know it
and why don't they use korean figures is
it because that history is just that is
there's no career outside of kimiyong
that is a great question because i spoke
to some refugees and they don't teach
them geography
so the nations they're aware of are
korea china
russia japan the us that might be the
list
so they didn't know about hiroshima or
nagasaki they don't teach them that
maybe they teach them to hate israel
because we're israel the u.s and japan
are the axis of evil uh according to
them
um so those examples that's a very very
good question they would not
be teaching them about copernicus uh or
columbus in school but it's what's funny
is
so there's a kimmel song supposedly
could teleport
one of the ways he defeated the wicked
jet bastards was using land shrinking
magic
so i spoke to a refugee i go
was he literally teleporting was this
like a metaphor for like
oh you know you never know where he's
coming next and she goes no no literally
and i'm like did they talk about how he
learned to teleport
and they're like no he just he can do it
you know and she's like i honestly
believe that if he wrote his name on a
piece of paper the
the name could fly away and i'm like is
that a function of the ink
is the paper staying um so
but those stories are not translated
so she said they know that the really
wacky stuff
to keep internal so they play and also
like i read a lot of books and there'll
be a reference to some particularly
crazy north korean story
and then i follow the footnote to their
archives and that story's been pulled
so they liked my book cover on instagram
they play the west
very very well if you convince uh
florence king the former national review
writer once said she can't wait to be
looked at as the crazy old lady
because once you're crazy old lady
you're allowed anything you know no
one's going to be like what's she doing
well she's a crazy old lady
so if you convince everyone on earth
that you're completely crazy and
compress that
that nuclear button at any moment you
really are in their heads
and have a big sense of power over them
because they're going to be
who isn't scared of a crazy person i'm
scared of crazy people
do you get any insight into what china
thinks about all this
yes uh so china is basically north
korea's last ally
and they have had it um
but north korea is a very soviet nation
in many ways
and just like my people they
love uh they kind of get off on being
defiant
so a lot all of you who are like signing
facebook petitions to tell putin to stop
gay
you know to be for gay rights that's
really gonna get you a lot of traction
in in russia in the other direction
um and so when china's like guys let's
reign it in
they're like no what are you gonna do
about it and in fact the reason the
eldest son wasn't chosen as a successor
is he said we need to be more like
beijing we need to be more like the west
kim jong-il suffer himself the economic
miracle that happened in china
and kim jong-il said absolutely not
we're not chinese
we are sticking through the korean juche
idea through thick and thin
and if you want openness open a window
the big bad ussr collapsed without
firing a shot economics and so forth and
that was more if i can use the term
civilized country
you might say than than north korea you
have a fix
on their military might i mean i know
they have rockets and stuff
well they have the fourth biggest army
on earth yeah that's that's fine but you
can
obliterate them with a bomb the question
is the technology
the nuclear and stuff do you do you give
much credibility to their nuclear they
100
have nukes there's no question that they
have nukes the question is delivery
and would they fire them i do not
believe that they would fire them for
seoul
i have no doubt that they would aim for
tokyo uh if they could reach the us they
would aim for the us too but again
for a nation that's been suicidal and
crazy they've outlasted
everybody else so it's really so either
they're really bad at being suicidal
or they're or they're really good at
something else
and my vote is for the second one
and again part of the reason part of
what i tried to do with this book
uh is to get people to have
understanding of you know they're not
these crazy suicidal people they
have a coherent philosophy that doesn't
work for them but certainly maintains
the regime in power despite you know the
rest of world being utterly against them
uh one more question yes
i also want to ask this because in ego
and hubris they talk about you it's a
graphic comic book
it talks about you're always being right
about everything and i'm reading this
and thinking
did you really identify with your
subject yeah
because he's always right i'm here and
he's dead
so clearly one of us was always writing
the other one wasn't no if you're
so for those who don't know harvey
picard of american splendor fame
uh wrote a graphic novel about my life
entitled ego and hubris which ends on an
iran quote
um and it's the story
people ask me to sum it up in one
sentence and there's there's a couple of
answers it's
a the little engine that could but
shouldn't
or it's about a young boy who thought he
was better than everybody else and was
and that one i really do believe because
the book but it's the
but i still got my wings uh the the
reason why it's the opposite of kim
jong-il is the book which every
uh la se fair books you know referred to
me as the hero of my own life
it's a series of me going against
authority figures
teachers principals bosses you know who
are all
you know reprehensible awful people and
taking them down on their own terms
and this was not easy to do and i take
great pride
in having the courage of my convictions
when i did uh reading the fountain had
certainly had a lot to do with that
uh i didn't blow up a building but you
know
if it happened i wouldn't be too sad
about it uh having worked at goldman
sachs
um but i never
try to force my views on other people
if you want to have different
perspectives that's fine go live your
life it's a very big world
this is in north korea go live anywhere
you want
just don't come to my house
well dear writer thank you very much for
your insight say thank everyone for
coming
um for recent magazines this is
you